all right in Muay or love welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 89 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got a two actually two
special guests we've got MVD and the
singleplayer effects of black ops for
x-box asian division pokemon gold and
spider-man DLC impressions to discuss so
we gonna get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who's balanced and
objective personality in regards to the
gaming industry is truly refreshing to
watch not only just Lord the embodiment
of what it means to be a true gamer but
similar to the ILP this law respects all
platforms and game genres while at the
same time you define a podcast community
introducing that creator and host of the
W DFC podcast and co-host of the
original nlg podcast the Lord of Ford
Mustangs and all things Texas sports and
the very first Lord to give Lord kognito
in the IOP a taste of their own
introduction medicine making his debut
into the realm of the Lord's mommy lost
fastback 67-68 how you doing sir you got
it you got it
what's going on brother I am honored I'm
excited big fan of you guys you know I'm
ready long overdue with you too bad what
they do this for Wow we got WTF seeing a
building LLG in a building it's gonna be
fun today man I'm hight ready cause I
want to introduce a lord who I first had
the opportunity to cross paths with III
2015 and is an absolute pleasure for all
the lords to see at each and every
Microsoft event this Lord of one of is
one of the most passionate members of
the Xbox community
consistently rubbed shoulders with all
gaming royalty yet at the same time is
the most inclusive and humble Lord to
ever interact with introducing the
creator of the legendary txr podcast and
one of the pillars in the Xbox community
the coolest Lord in the realm and by far
the most requested gamertag to be sold
in Xbox Live history finally making his
debut into the realm of the Lord
mommy no it's southbound 110 how you
doing sir
oh man that that intro bro yeah how can
you be like finish off a podcast with
intros like that I'm like you know it's
been a long time coming and I just
that's why I think you get for having me
thanks man yo so good to have you both
in the buildin southbound you know this
is long overdue this is this is like
royalty this is family friend so we go
add some finally Damon I'm having all of
you know we got the Four Horsemen of
gaming those original Lords of the realm
here at the round table
my co-host with the co-host my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the house of the young
wolf mommy
Lord addict how you doing sir I'm doing
pretty good I've been playing a lot of
Assassin's Creed Odyssey or a god see
how I like to say you know I'm still
like 40 hours in this game and I'm still
only level 28
that's a game to you yeah you know what
I like I like the fact that uh before
you know all this stupid internet crap
people used to have an opinion you gotta
be tuned you're a robot all maybe
working that uh that you're not going to
attack me for night comes to reviews
it's like if I don't give a game of ten
out of ten like seventy six it's been a
lot of what you call it yeah yeah really
enjoy the game been playing a little bit
of Final Fantasy thirteen like it's
crazy like I don't even have an ex I
have an S and it's crazy like this game
looks like it came out this gen lady
really did they did a good job on the
you know that upward scaling right like
you know Microsoft did a lot of really
good work with that but nothing square
enix you know had a game that came out
ahead of its time - mhm mhm that's
what's up again every every area it was
a downgrade but in the visualize
definitely an upgrade back that's what's
up yo shout to the back would compacting
them guys and that bills doing a crew
fantastic job with that one
no doubt add a good to have you back you
will miss and of course you know we have
the most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives with a single player
selfish experience and also disaster
Damas mister off my profile Illuminati
and Lord patreon of the iron baked fresh
off his vacation sovereign are you doing
I am doing great man hear me him a voice
like I'm rest all day yesterday got home
home later the active flight was delayed
a little bit got home they wouldn't
expect it but I just left we've got all
all the mojitos out of my system you
know just like it was it was low-key oh
yeah I was doing it up no I was low-key
I mean you always when you go there you
always gotta see family and no matter
how much time is over they're like four
days so it was just like Friday was
running around the saying hi and bye
everybody
oh you know Thanksgiving was low-key
quiet just stuff my face did nothing but
you always have your days there we go
see like friends and whatnot and hang
out and just make sure you got over some
of the craziness over there but it was
good it was good and obviously the
weather because I heard things about
Thanksgiving over it was crazy in New
York City people bundle I say oh it's
one of those years much in the way game
like took the switch with me never took
it out of the case didn't happen in the
case I try to catch up on some some
Netflix man like I watch the show I
watched all of Castlevania it's a season
two steams into that is the best
Castlevania thing I've ever seen I don't
even want obviously I don't want to
decassle video games anymore I want like
this blown out 3d like Lord the shadow
was good but I like I want story like
that that was correct
characters every that was fantastic
and I'm almost done watching the
haunting of Hill House if you haven't
seen that see that no dough no real
quick before I pass again on did you get
to say it chance to see geriatric three
we have the incredible hulk of this aka
the XS gamer the Lord of combat sports
was a premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud got a crazy story I
really want to tell that story real
quick and then I can get into what I'm
playing and then up this is the police
if like you're being a fraud you're slow
[Applause]
he's on point though
so check it out right we go upstairs to
stop party and we get up there Mikey bar
and everybody's up there southbound
everybody's pop and all
nobody handing out shirts so they
thought we was a gang right um because
we come over there we're all purple and
gold and we've got a gang reppin to the
biggest do I had to respect his hustle
because he was like I'm a total to the
biggest do we a podcast oh okay okay cuz
you know la got gang culture so you got
to respect exactly that right so it's
outbound and everybody but we're leaving
alright and as we're leaving we're
getting into elevators and um there's C
okay this is where the racism comes in
we're all packing in the elevator and
southbound is a little loud and it seems
to me that there's a asian lady standing
in front of the elevator so she's in
front of the elevator looking in it
she's like nah there's too many people
I'm not gonna do that
southbound proceeds to grab this lady's
hand and yank her inside the elevator so
I said oh my god we got a seam I said we
gonna get arrested because this man is
ranking this woman inside this damn
elevator
so again we go to the next elevator and
he proceeds to muscle her into the I'm
like yo on everything I know we catching
a case we got all these they're gonna
look for us he was straight boss with it
like boss with it
I'm afraid I'm letting you we gotta get
to the cars and get the hell out of here
all right we leave the next day I see
southbound at the center III he's there
with the same here's my racism
she looks so beautiful together and he
had me scared to death myself my wife
heard heard you talk about before
shout out to Tito I know was coming no
cuz Tito actually looked in shape Chuck
Liddell looking like a moving corpse out
there he got a check shoutout to ask her
for milking the old let me say something
real quick lourdes who had the funniest
tweet about it he said that when Tito
grabbed the bag it was awesome
and if you like that what golden boy
come over here like a death-row moment
in bags but right now this week I
finished God walk on a hundred percent
of platinum hate Natick what would you
baby yeah and I start a game plus and
then I switched over to spider-man
because that DLC came out how about that
baby then then I'm on No
Kunie - no I'm in the middle of that and
it's it's phenomenal that's so I got a
back load of games remember that came
out in January it was still in the
wrapper I should have opened it up I
brought a full price when it came I
gotta brought it now for like 20 bucks
mom
but this PlayStation a lot of people are
hating on me right now because I'm on my
playstation bag and I got to get to
these games because I'm a gamer so I'm
not gonna sit there and tie myself to
one system and don't enjoy what I got
but it doesn't matter what you're
playing there's all your playing that's
right I think that's how it was supposed
to be everybody knows I'm a big sports
fan but I don't hate on somebody that's
a strong fan you know I mean that didn't
Lake like everybody got different
flavors everybody's likes different pair
of Jordans everybody likes to prepare
gene courage listen we're not all cut
from the same cloth so really we're all
family eh I got brothers and sisters or
I don't even like like yeah but like I
said I'll put cocaine I saw you talking
about you know I was gonna say one quick
comment on that fight I almost felt like
like Tito set him up we don't say like
Tito but what time it was he knew this
man he fighting like eight years or
whatever whatever and it just reminds me
when the old superstar had too much
hubris and he just doesn't want to know
when to stop you know sir so it's just
I've seen that episode and fight it
happened so many times yeah he it's not
too hard so it would be a Chuck got a
chill just the money thing man and
payday like I think Chuck knew he was
going down there was more than that he
got paid more than hey you got paid yeah
pretty much but he knew what was coming
man he shaped to be fight Tito yeah hey
Jenna still need that money
we're gonna go into that later that's
like one of the top you gotta get a
chance to UM hear my opinion about it
and I'm gonna explain why I think they
did a DLC package um and I should make a
little bit of sense no doubt of course
we have the game of ninja himself the
shinobi lore kognito spreading that
ruinous in the realm of the ILP not
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear so for me it's
just been on final step by that read
requests I'm done with it just the
prestige and I'll be done be over
without d2 um like the warframe for the
switch very impressed you know online
functionality was there voice chat
without the Nintendo repeater bro voice
chat son it could be done but saying
like oh here we go hey I don't think you
know something oh oh boy here we go
you know for you know every platform
oh so god forbid the switch gets any
type of big deal shout out to ash and
Luka I was supposed to be on her show
yesterday and the scum cast team as you
apologize for what happened yesterday I
had an unfortunate thing being a boss
you know a lot of things happen there's
a lot of moving parts and but my stupid
behind saw her say 4:15 and my new your
brain I didn't see the seed st actually
a hitter like yeah more I can be all
four hours some change the slow-mo is
all good yes
but see I wanted to do to shouts I was
earlie up super early so she was like
what are you talking about this hour
from now I'm so sorry I really wanted to
be on the show so I do apologize and I
hope that next week or whatever you do
it you know you hit me the link and I
get there yeah but I do apologize what
happened - out the King not knowing CST
like we had to go back and forth through
time like wait hold on a second what
time my new PC is inbound addict it's
coming there I got my date is supposed
to be on next Tuesday or Wednesday so
look out for the master race or your
master race guys hit me I just wanna
know what that [ __ ] by like there's like
a team of sales pick up the this thing
to the Hawks and then the Hawks drop it
off to the 1500 with a 20 80 I'm kind of
everybody getting new PCs and I'm trying
to hold my head a little bit hating like
I had to these deals are too good idea
bothers hooking me up with some great
deals and stuff so it's gonna be late so
yeah man that's pretty much it so ah now
that we've gotten into what the lords
have been playing I want to start off
with Lord Fastback first his video game
system history his journey into YouTube
and creating the WTF C podcast and of
course one of our favorites the amazing
LG podcast so more fast but let's get it
what was doing first video game systems
you had and watching the game alright so
I'm going old-school in that now after
others still on this one out pong oh
okay we got that from our grandfather
nice so me my brother and you know
sooner we got that play it going back
and forward back and forth is cool right
let's go back outside and then I would
say maybe a couple years later same
thing grandfather gave my dad here
either get the kids a Atari 2600 the
grandpa he was on point I think I don't
the mini gave it to us I don't know we
got his second hand right but yeah you
know soon as we got that you know
Frogger you know you see the course and
what the hell's going on and great at
2600 a what grain yeah no no we actually
we had a bigger TV you know in the wood
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go tell about it let's go
just yell in school right now my brother
were playing darts over the top on the
on the wall but the TV Wow from how the
pan on the back was off and then somehow
the dartboard filmed the back is like we
can hear the TV we can't see any big boy
it's messed up that she has to listen to
this podcast here what the hell happened
to the guy
what else got fans man so you know real
quick on the Atari you know one of the
main games that played a lot on there
was some football game right okay I
remember someone posting it but uh so
you know when I was playing it and I
discovered there's that turbo on the
back of the deal switch so you know
players one my brother just can't figure
out why the hell I was beating his ass
all right so then after that somehow we
were poor you know little section eight
hood there we go and humble beginnings
as we gonna call it I feel bad I feel
bad you feel sorry for him yeah
so she find him stuff so he went to the
hospital or whatever with the brand-new
Wow but you know that sorry went in the
closet I tell you what in the bushes we
sort of s Rockets yeah all Mario after
that you know and even when the first in
Deus was you know it then we got tired
in it's like get some alcohol
everybody had those cars I understand
like when you know now we're connecting
with everybody on social media but and
you know hear people say they never had
in the 10 I'm like could you not have
have had a Nintendo back in the day that
they was born yesterday forget man
there's a lot of Millennials around you
know
after 1992 Oh like bike from energy to
chat right they didn't start off with
the Nintendo so what's wrong there was
outside living life well no they Sega
kids were kind of in our own little box
NES was the weight like let's make this
be clear like any us that had the mind
share you don't I'm saying and mass was
like yeah they didn't say it it hit its
stride until Genesis came then it was
like okay now it's more of a fight to
our Lord Gordon who corrected us on that
because when we had him on he showed us
how like in the European territories how
mass system was really doing well so you
are correcting continued aspect you
gotta remember it was until Sonic came
out to did say it just blew up
oh yeah but you know how you know how
then all those take offense and you know
after that commercial Nintendo oh yes
okay you say Nintendo but stake it say
God you know he still he still some
greta nintendo power for that we can
convince mom by that all this extra
accessories but right so need one you
don't need a gallbladder
you know we get past the NES and then we
ended up super nes came on board and I
guess said that my brother didn't have
to get sick for that my dad you know
gave my mom some money you know that was
wrong Christmas but the soup is fine
it's my all-time favorite console fire
baseball yeah you know and I'll tell you
what I had more fun playing sports games
nowadays but let me ask you this though
cuz you're the sports guy right I'm
shocked that did you miss out on the
jitters cuz let's keep it a bug Genesis
know what was that Wade football I'm
kind of surprised that you never maybe
did you eventually get a Genesis later
on but just for the poorest so
miscellaneous any effort super in
there's pretty much majority of my youth
okay I you know got out of high school
around high school when I graduated my
brother went to go live with dad well he
started getting into the Sega so he had
the Genesis he had the Saturn he had the
most one after that yeah
so hear all that so every time so after
the defenders except when I would come
back home little Perry when I come back
home I jump on the the Sega's you know
in Genesis and coming home and he had
the Saturn in sight the hell's the
super-stretch it was okay that was okay
majority Tommy played a lot of you know
sports or whatever
honestly I don't know what else yeah
that was too busy running around chasing
women and
ouu evolves over matter
around that time I wasn't gaming a lot
mmm so good so once I said oh I started
working I'm still going to school so I
had any the 64 so I'm gonna move nice
and now it's probably the first system
actually bought with my own money cuz
all the other than attended you know
that Sega's at you know that was the
parents mmm-hmm so I picked up the
joystick is for an auto which you have
what you know I played the you know the
the Mario plane one of my favorite games
was were Ocarina fire but I didn't play
much I started in SR jumping the PCE PCs
are coming around it's like a a or AOL
stuff yeah that I had two and a half
hours for free
started in RTS start playing with others
you know like command conquer and Red
Alert
what about that I'm seven mm-hmm
I remember Deus Ex the first one I'm PC
yeah that's me that's me that's the slow
well let me see if I can upgrade my
computer gaming and I started looking
into it you know how much is gonna cost
me and I in
you look member back then you or I'm
fine with you now you look in the back
suspects and I run that's what you know
then I jumped up ps1 nice ooh nice
and then of course 360 ever since I plan
a little bit of everything
my console nowadays is xbox okay oh yeah
I miss I missed the racism days of 360
and online I missed like a ten-year-old
telling you how good your mom is in the
sack it was so good it was the wild wild
west and it was so much fun like so many
people in chair weirdos like you play a
game and you mixed up with different
people and you got so much disrespect
point though cuz you know it wasn't it
wasn't the racism for me but it was back
then see the different we all are named
and online now is that all and in was
mandatory like now because of party chat
I'm not engaging like the winner of them
to anything is you're not making friends
like you're not making new friends you
stayed your rice I'll be staying with
your saying click the corner but you're
still playing and interacting with other
people and you're not talking to each
other and like cuz we get these
blueberries and destiny but wouldn't it
be hot if you weren't in there and
everybody was able to talk like that no
it was fast the only thing that's off
gets up well remember it call duty
they're like well hold on oh no this
party cat stuff yes and guess what
I missed the mandatory party chat
disabled feature when you play the game
like modern warfare and then like look
you can't play party chat right now you
have to help me whenever you know once
you start playing Halo online with
everybody I don't know why chose God
love the [ __ ] out Halen but I chose
chief Halo 24seven online and if I
didn't do good I heard it you know you
ain't no chief chief halo I missed some
of those the back and forth but I don't
miss the stupid you know the kids
talking smack cussing the racism that's
true man y'all want to talk to her but
shout out shout out the og I mean the
new on what is it the group finder
feature Xbox Live has 11 yeah that
built-in LMG you can kind of get a
little bit of that feel back because it
kind of forced you to interact what
people could tell you fast back you were
saying no I mean and just you know all
right now just you know pretty much
current on you know they got the x2
picked up the X during the Black Friday
sales Oh
I will get a probe probably Nick sure
whenever they announce appears fire
don't do that don't get approached the
God of War and spider-man all that no
doubt it's like 1999 did a good deal on
the switch for the Black Friday night
know you know I did pick up by fire
controller the pro controller okay I
look through don't that's a service so
tremendous tremendous history as always
you know I'm saying I wanted to ask you
real quick about the young obviously the
creation of two podcast your honor one
is the wdf see I'm saying that crass
acronym with two leanings we're not
gonna say what one meaning is on the
Lord's Day shut up shut up the witty the
Lord they're super cool for the crew and
then also what led you to becoming a
member of the image and LG what's
thinking crazy hdk in them guys so you
know gee I've been falling on for quite
a bit way back you know and they had a
they had a Enrique um you know with my
Greek and my boy there's a long time he
had a couple other members and some
other guy cameras named Steiner few
times
Ricky started a story one when Enrique
first started it was him myself and
worrywart it's not the burger at any a a
Enrique's lost Internet one time right
and we're still you know we're chopping
up we're just kind of laughing you know
goofing around and everything and Ricky
just ghosted us right and we're like
this is his so what do we do
a sudden worry just says I guess is my
show and takes over so weird like for
the next like 10-15 minutes that you
know Enrique losses the internet
connection
we're just clowning we're just singing
and dancing back and he's in tears like
what the hell you know dance a chicken
look deep in the files you'll find it
fast like southbounder saying like you
know from energy to follow energy if the
whole time and I've always stayed there
and supported you know Mike no matter
who he said you know you know after
Enrique he brought in what was his name
will be no well he brought in hdk and he
had crazy one it was another guy but his
nickname who was caught woohoo said
these nuts with him Wow interesting
yeah that was just Western Drake and
mods so they've been through quite a bit
and so you know I had been on energy as
a guest before da Chang
so Mike approached me and say hey you
know but definitely want to get you on
you know you thought him you know you're
the first person I thought of and you
know you've been a friend you know we be
him to get a game with htk and Mike and
then just get along we got you know good
chemistry and I enjoyed being with those
guys and I want to give a shout out to
him Enrique he's the first one to give
me a shot on the podcast ass with Brent
yes
recognize a that's was so
so you know after a while then you know
me coupe and and we start talking like
hey let's just start a podcast just for
fun you know just that you know whatever
so you know then we brought weeding and
then dad's jumped in that's kind of a
crazy day that's why one know I'm trying
to figure that out because like the
moderator of the universe he's moderated
everyone's podcast yeah
you know so wit Easter day I got this
guy over here that is pretty cool and
you know you moderate like that all
right
you know get him on the show and then
after that right we just had a good time
it's like so ready you want to be on
permanent sure used to be WFC be in
there and change it to WFC date myself
you know like it was like now oh yeah we
hooked whatever but back in the days it
was just a casual encounter
we're scamming for about six months last
year whichever you want talking about
you know just it's just fun you know you
know we invite anybody anybody's invited
you know it's like one time I invited
seen I know he was busy but he didn't
catch it till later but it's like I
don't care who's on everybody's cool you
know just jump in and that's the way WC
is not planting nothing's planned
sometimes you just wing it and you know
let's go you know whatever happens man
you got a brand or anything like that no
shower for y'all for having me and uh
like I say it so fast like you're the
first bed give me an intro i was WTF see
here write some words with some balls I
took it to the next level yeah the
Chicago Bulls here at the end now for me
I was hyped shout out to you guys my
guys doing your thing so I gotta ask you
the question I asked all the guests
lower Fastback I need that top 5 dead or
alive best games of franchises for fast
bet I'm ready for this Turner who was it
that on Twitter said this question to
kind of catch people who don't worry
southbound next so I thought about how
to go out in the country and where it's
quiet and think about this let's call so
in really no particular order but I put
my number one in the front but so I'm
gonna start off with going back I might
start off with Mario mmm classy because
like oh when NES came out
- easy to say it came out that it was
all about Hospital Oh what's Nova - you
got Mario Mario you know Tori was fun
and all that right but when you got the
NES and you popped in that Mario game
you like oh she's over there how come
you drop a bomb all over the place and I
just say you about to get muted right
now we put him on
timeout for five minutes so no I mean
the the Mario game changed everything
from me my brother
as far as gamer took you to that next
level you know that platformer you know
you know you kept repeating trying to
beat the your time from before you had
to secrets like you didn't know before
you taught the brand Mario is the first
as far as really brought you into the
platforming and all that bags overdose
as we got through this day you can still
play Mario I mean kids nowadays you know
mm-hmm
the next one is no good okay Samus is
irate with you bust your balls brother I
know but Zelda his first game that
introduced open-world you know kind of
eg in a way mm-hmm and you had a story
you had you know you had quests you you
know pick up I have to call fraud or on
disrespect to this be interacting with
NPCs and picking up items you know you
can finding that special sword shield
I'm intrigued of all that you know bags
number three we're gonna go with the
halo right that's as simple as Mario
come on
now the reason why I picked more halo
when I first came out I didn't jump on
it right away right you know playing on
ps2 you know mm-hmm if he's doing only
system that had GTA those like yes not
correct one so when Halo came out my
friend started you know picked it up
doji changed and they started praying
yeah you know playing together hooking
up there doji Xboxes and then I was like
so we started having garage parties Oh
land party with the TVs you know just
having fun drinking Oh Fastback which
one of your friends found out that you
could hook them up though
because there's always one in the group
that finds out that this function can
happen sovereigns here so sovereign
found out the dysfunction and it can
happen and when that happened the whole
game change because the first show more
people on one swing trees I don't like
the screen sharing I'd you know it's
like you like y'all go ahead to get
y'all a lot of cheating man like you
know you watch some screen watch put a
piece of cardboard in parties you had
you know when you have 16 people yet for
people any you know TV so you stir so
you know I mean that just took it to the
next level playing together you know 16
of us or that you know remember I gotta
give a shout-out to double-oh-seven
go tonight you know for you know teaming
up on you know so alright so right halo
that legendary ain't got two more where
it's gaming together oh nice okay there
we go
does that change things to as far as you
know pull toward then it's like oh I've
got to play Mass Effect I play Dragon
Age and you know so and of course Star
Wars my number one might get some I
don't know if I'll get some heat for
this from battlefront : oh my number one
game all time is super technical it was
Bo Jackson was the crazy dude right
that's the only game with offensive line
don't get ever call for holding Oh you
your screen watching you saw me pick the
play that's how you knew you know how
when everybody would just rush and they
yeah so much fun and pissing off my
brother because I was better than him
but I even when I got older I you know I
prayed with another guy who was you know
when I used to work with so he said they
didn't give me a ride home alright
say you ever play super yeah so we
played you first play with someone you
kind of have to kind of fill it out the
real out process yes sound like a
beginning to a dog you know a lot of
people like to pay 49ers and of course
the Raiders there that's right baby them
- lets go yeah I enjoyed playing with
the Cowboys of course boilers was that
the moon era was that yes classic game
so underrated a sports title yes so
having the first sports title in his top
5 a lot of people never did that and
that wasn't a safe pick either and that
was a safe you killed that man I got a
shout you out on that you gave it so
next up and long-overdue we got to keep
it real because the show is going to be
long oh lord South let us briefly talk
about video game system history as well
as getting started as a content creator
and of course one of the legends in the
game so what was the first
yo game system you had y-yeah that's
that's like right here at a pride 86 we
got of course we got the Nintendo you
know we had the old-school TVs only had
three channels already bang but we did
we didn't care about that window when
the channels went out TV station said
it's time to go to bed that's when it
was time for the Nintendo and we say in
Tendo Ford that first everybody that's
crazy
ah you know there is no Nintendo in
Tendo and then hey you know I had a
Super Nintendo for a while like I said I
only play sports games back then
honestly am i in my teens I wasn't a big
gamer I hadn't had two Sega Genesis nor
me it wasn't like the Sega Saturn came
out where World Series baseball that was
baseball and what was what was the
racing game that came with
cruisin USA or something what was it hey
go rally Oh Daytona
that's what it was yeah right there and
then you know a little bit of lore craft
when it came to Saturn but not too much
you know what kind of I you know I was
out running amok you know a scam so
finally I got to you know because I like
I said I really wasn't in the game but I
I started filling by city and it was by
city and I like Ace Combat and I messed
around with a little bit of what's it
called now I just top my head I could
think of the remedy game what's his name
Oh Max Payne 2 when you're going through
that little nightmare sequence and
you're following the blood and you fall
off it was like 2 o'clock in the
afternoon and I was scared I was like
put my chest out a little bit I'm like
and it wasn't until my homeboy brought
home he was my roommate in time he
brought home an Xbox the original xbox
OG with Halo and most recon to now
recall was fire and I know like like
like fast back said you know Halo really
wasn't my thing back then right the
first person they sued you you know halo
to Susan you know when you started
getting the controls and you had the
captain right there next to you and you
guys start moving around all the a I
popped in that Ghost Recon and it was
like damn buy me an Xbox not myself I
went out and got that you know Cable
Internet oh my god it was like are you
douchebag 101 yeah that one was special
for me to like I think that was one of
the early Xbox Live
no ma'am you know what we played that
game for even when the 360 came out
we're still playing go through and then
they made their patch for the 360 so
you're able to play it on the new a that
game we could not get away from it so
good so good you know it was cool
because you know being able to go to e3
and everything and I got to meet
Christian Allen who was the creator on
Ghost Recon and so like you was like one
of my heroes you know I mean so being
able to meet people like that you know
like dude you know how many hours I
poured in your game and have any second
I bought that title hey you know it it's
like it's amazing to be able to like to
meet you know letting your quote-unquote
heroes know absolute I want to
transition that because um you know you
as og you know my first e3 you kind of
introduced me to a lot of these people
you said a lot of things I think a lot
of people don't want to do that you know
I mean they're afraid someone they step
on their toes like oh five if I
introduce this person to somebody and
you know they'll be forgotten about
he'll know it's all family nor because
hey you extend an olive branch that
becomes a tree for you man because like
I said like you know I'm the new new kid
on the block you know I didn't know
anybody come through come through meet
this it was a whole bunch of people I
think shouted David pre in that day he
was there yeah you control there was a
lot of people me being honest I was just
chopping up talking back a few you know
I'm saying we had a good time we got two
tickets you go only twice Beast
there's a beast but now always
appreciate yourself because that was
love it was not exactly because you know
in a day III is a celebration and it's
all family you know what I mean
even for the haters you know I mean it's
all good well they compete in next year
quick selfie I want to take take it out
of every layer would it start troubled I
got I got a ask you know say because at
the end of the day you know when I look
at what you've accomplished and how your
fixture in the community and then I just
remember you know like Fastback say like
I remember TX aw man you know I was my
favorite man like you guys I they called
you guys like the six Voltron lions you
don't say it was you Tim dog ran maka
inferno doc like just hi nahi come
together we go talk about no ending no
drama
listen you know cakes are is kind of
like a love story even though yeah then
you get your heart broken
you still look back with fond memories
you know I mean because you have life
experience because of it sacks so you
know you know at the time you know there
was there was a couple podcasts out
there you know I mean the more uh
controversial ones you know what I mean
yes and I I wanted some kind of like
more uh not so much console neutral but
more like open-minded hmm you know I
mean so I wanted to kind of like broaden
the horizons in and like I said I'm not
trying to diss you know like Tim dog you
know was part of crap entire but you
know I mean they they were doing their
thing shout out to them
Charlton well I but I wanted to do
something a little bit different you
know I mean I wanted to people like I
said with an open mind to come and say
oh you know what okay and then their
Xbox fan but you know what they're not
sitting there trashing so you know so at
first it was it was basically Tim and I
you know we're kicking it back and forth
you know we kind of like think about our
lineup you know and I was like why first
were like well should we have like a
roving person every week and that I was
originally the idea hmm
and then we just kind of like okay then
we start talking to ran right South the
Lord brain yeah and then like you know
then all of a sudden he was a permanent
fixture and then like so as you know the
idea kept you know snowballing again
bigger you know I mean we're like
alright doc you know you know what I
mean exactly and so it's just when a
time came we went you know we would
douve right in head first and then you
know couple episodes in we had like I
said we're still you know still you guys
experimenting with the you know the
guests every week and oh Mack he jumped
on and he enjoyed it you know what I
mean
so it really surprised because you know
he had his own youtubers on he yeah yeah
he's a big dude in his own right so for
him wanting to join us really surprised
me
yeah court open arms you know like I
said so everybody put their own stamp on
txr you know and so for the I don't know
when a firm okay he's the latest one
yeah he was the last one cuz they hate
okay yeah yeah we had I won't say issue
but doc would got busy norming so like
you know when somebody's schedule
against except yeah that's all so you
know I mean so doc had to bounce out so
we say you know what the fertile the
talent to do you know why don't we bring
him in I said you know he had filled in
for us one time and and and at the time
I was missing a few shows mm-hmm my
grandfather had passed away so I was at
a snake yeah you know I mean no it's the
worst but you know you get over it you
know life goes on
mm-hmm so you know I was missing a few
shows and so it Ferno really helped out
myself because he you know he's
up-up and he you know he's build a
little bit of that void that I left
mm-hmm and so uh so yeah so you know in
the end like I said I you know I'm a
little bitter because we don't have it
no more outside too late you know our
options come doing in you know I don't
get I would love to do a reunion show
you just read my mind cuz now we gotta
talk about this is part of lorkhan
needles master now what I wanted to say
cuz we all missed EXO on the first I'm
gonna give full discos like that was one
of my favorite podcast like for me to
get in the game
I definitely listen in your study jar
like it was a million so I was super sad
to see you go but at the same time like
just almost like the temptations you
gotta Rock the shiny would you be
definitely alright it's all it's tab
still deliver you know I mean I might
miss it too much new edition just came
back bro
Lord South would be willing so I got to
reach out to the other Voltron lion see
we could do this you know Sam but that
was one of my favorite salute shock man
that dad was in the more thank you you
know and it's funny because I'm not
trying to say oh we started this cuz we
didn't you know I mean we just I was
gonna do it yeah we went our own lane
you know we try that we try to do
something a little bit different and but
now you know you see like all the
podcast you know popping out from you
know left-to-right and it's honestly
just touching you know I mean is that I
hope that we left a little bit of
lasting you know smart
ya know you've sparked a lot of us
absolutely because it was a lot of love
that went into it you know what I mean
and it wasn't just love for gaming it
was a love for for each other and and
talking and you know just chopping it up
on every every week in fact definitely
man like I said the IOP definitely was
inspired by you guys I remember when
like I said when we got the announcement
I reached out to all you guys
individually and just want to say my
thanks because at the end of the day
like I said it was it was passionate it
was informative it was funny you know
I'm saying and you guys just really had
a good chemistry so again salute which I
might do that one night we're gonna
bring it back to south so we gotta get
out of this segment real quick so you
know honestly I don't have a top five
but I will go down a list that's good no
particular order let's go I'm a break
yeah a fall out number two I'll go take
it back to Ghost Recon because that's
what started me on this online
stuff okay I'm gonna go easy like
fastback GT a okay flipping you off
right now GTA you talking about you talk
about the top-down GTA people in the
street by City hey I put down the
controller I thought I was a drug dealer
in Miami with Mass Effect but you know
what hey I put a lot of my life into
that trilogy you know I mean the
character and my my Stepford was ended
when you guys were like we're rushing up
into the spaceship you know I mean it
could be like you know uh what was that
the female movie when they they flew up
to the the ledge well you gotta make a
choice you wanna kill everybody you want
to save everybody everybody has a
different light halo on the ps2 when
you're doing that lining up for when
you're doing your when your soon people
you know I mean when a they call you out
come on partner we don't step outside
and I always got blastx I can never line
up the two dots marijuana going around
but my thumb's are look slow it was I
basically got it you know like it was a
flesh wound but I still got it
still got memory lane we could talk
forever never do a show with the dish
right yo well you're fantastic guys so
yo last week's poll results are in and
the people have spoken to the question
with the recent announcement of Sony not
attending no holding an off-site press
conference during e3 is this a mistake
by Sony to skip on gaming's largest
event of the year the winner a 63% is
the yes Sony skipping III is a
promotional misstep and breeds arrogance
group coming in at a surprising second
place at 21% was the a Nokia ghosted
Toshiba fruit man in the 60 we say it
was the no III is overrated and Sony can
gear up for ps5 as the market leader
group thanks to all those who don't have
a choice people are saying that that's
the superfans you know what I mean
because really I mean let's be honest
you know and I'm I'm gonna take off my
xbox hat for a second all right Sony
pulled out of e3 is nothing but a bad
thing because you know and we talked
about this on crossfire like what
happens to all Sony's partners that
they're supposed to be showing off their
games so addicts about them you know I'm
really happy that you know Sony is
flipping the bird to these dudes no no
seriously seriously I'm happy because
you chose somebody that didn't care
about you but I'm happy that that
happened because Microsoft we have a
home come on
we just stop you're gonna be real sorry
one second but in the chat Dan said it
earlier you know you've gone through
your story in your history but they said
on the Microsoft no exclusive is coming
on next year's called III back on you
know that whole poll wit Sony if he's
there I guess I'll go say I need your
feedback on that whole poll would Sony
like was disappointed I mean I and they
don't have much to show what days got is
going to be you know that's February
yeah and well I don't we don't even know
what else they have before III so in
like southbound said or they should
least be there to kind of sell you know
III to me is like a celebration of
gaming exclusive or third-party or not
they should at least have a dude show
off some third party stuff have
something on the floor to you know even
if the current games that are already
out know what I mean it you know just
the same that and for you guys I've
never been a three and one of these I
want to want to go and yes I'm hurt Xbox
gamer but I won't be disappointed if I
can't go and at least try something yeah
I think we talked about last week I
think for us at least for me
specifically it's more of the
competition aspect and the fact that
they're just they're not there at all
like it's one thing to say okay you're
not there but you're gonna have a
conference almost like a Nintendo but to
have no presence as always kinda it's
kind of like you said it's Erica you
know I mean but would we're bigger than
then III we're bigger than this it's
like okay yeah you do got you know the
mind share right now man you know people
are gonna learn from the past they're
doing to repeat it so will you get a
little bit too big for your britches
it's gonna suffocate you cry before the
four yes sir
that yeah we got to see how this plays
out I found everybody in a pole we got a
new one cooking up later no it's off you
are back got some stuff to talk about
black house what's going on let's listen
call the duty once again prove that it
is a machine beyond reproach even though
even though red that only had a couple
of days on the market before before the
shutdown it's still black Call of Duty
man like I have to and now get into I'll
get into that and so we have to bend the
leaf of duty man a damn card i swore up
and down i said you know what regardless
of what the response was to the removal
of singleplayer I'm like I don't know
man like I tell you this though if there
were no blackout mode this year Nigel
yeah I don't care
issuing that single player game was
gonna be in it was gonna I think I think
they had if no blackout was ready they
were just gonna try to sell you
multiplayer a regular card multiplayer
for 60 bucks I think you were gonna see
that single-player whatever state it was
it I think but I you know you gotta tip
your hat to them like it so I say this I
have to give a big shout out to all you
you Cod players and and I mean the real
Cod players the ones that are there
every single year regardless to what you
playing Cod because you you guys are a
special kind of dumbass thing about my
destiny brethren like I see you guys
what's the kind of play you know what I
mean like but the fact that you guys
gravitated to this regardless a
regardless of the whole single-player
stuff and how much everybody had to say
about that you know it just speaks to
your love of that game that franchise
period and your willingness to roll with
the punches regardless to what every
year big took about the ebbs and flows
of how its
selling less how it did the stand the
other it doesn't matter you guys look
there and all this talk about what what
Call of Duty needs to move forward what
what does it need to get revenge it
needed to remove the single-player
apparently to get and that turns me on
yeah you know whatever I think I think
that has it's gonna have a long ripple
effect and more repercussions in terms
of other single-player games and I mean
games that are in that ilk right I'm
talking about anything that's coming out
of EA scamp mostly right I'm not talking
I don't think it's an effect
single-player for like something like a
Wolfenstein Bethesda games or things
like that I don't think it's affecting
that at all those games are what they
are but I think moving forward the
success of this we're moving that
single-player I know they said the next
Call of Duty's gonna have single-player
but it's a while before we hear about
that game and I I would not be surprised
if they mysteriously come out and say
hey it wasn't coming together like and
start seeing that trend moving forward I
really do think this is gonna be for
cuttings on industry-wide in terms of
single-player for these types of games I
think it in particular he is gonna look
at the anthem is its own thing the way
that right and they're gonna see how
successful that game is or isn't based
on that model but when you look at
battlefront when you look at battlefield
when you look at titanfall are
especially titanfall and battlefront
that should be in the pipeline within
the next year to year and a half and you
see the successful flops for you got a
wonder if they're looking at okay so we
already we already effed up with the
loot boxes stuff we're not doing that
right we put in single player into
battlefront and that wasn't necessarily
received that great right mmm-hmm so
what can what can we do now to sort of
reinvigorate before and if you look at
battlefield right battlefield they've
gone with like single-player vignettes
right nothing I know which overarching
story nothing that they really have to
sort of stick to and you change up the
experience
you know every two or three hours Loki
will have been complaining about that
like [ __ ] even even been in in into
firstly people like hey why did you even
do that like they could have done
without it so that is interesting what
you said to me I think all of these
games the landscape of the the
single-player stuff in these but in
these multiplayer Centrex first-person
shooters I think it's gonna change a lot
with something he's gonna be 20 because
you don't they're gonna be like okay we
need to make this change in this
direction but how to make money off how
do we monetize it right right and they
can either have learned how to do that
properly and not piss people off more
it's gonna be the loot crate stuff all
over again
alright let me ask you a question was
before I give it to a wrestler like so
you your fear is because of the success
of a Call of Duty with the fact that
they remove single-player and they still
want an MPD they still beat a Red Dead
Redemption - like your fear is now that
other companies are gonna start
mimicking this practice other companies
of that same ilk they have games of that
same know you think affecting how they
you know them eliminating a single
player for them as much money as they
make your and you're out they were the
ones least affected by that they would
be the ones that I look at and be like
you know we can really sit regardless to
what the game is gonna sell great
regardless now right it feels to me it
feels like they're always looking at the
bottom line more and they always look
how do we streamline this to make the
most amount of money in the least amount
of time with the least amount of I don't
want to say at least amount of effort
put in but there's a lot of effort that
goes into a single-player campaign that
generally gets played through once if
that so EA is always looking at how to
monetize their product more over a
longer period of time whereas Call of
Duty you know you're getting a new one
in a year so yeah I just think it's
gonna it's gonna have an effect on how
those games look moving forward and I
think all that single-player stuff may
be going away of the dodo I really do
let me get at Acron Nevada cuz I know he
had to jump out his attic back I don't
know if he's back yet okay he might he
still might be gone all right so let me
get on let me get fast back on this man
fast what do you feel like do you think
this may have a snowball effect in
reference to you know single-player
campaigns yeah I mean I think to a
certain point like like a sovereign were
saying that you know who knows we could
see this going on with battlefield
battlefront going forward some of these
first-person shooter games now two
franchises I don't see this happening
it's Halo and Gears yes I mean kids to
me I look at those games those games are
story first and then you got multiplayer
which the multiplayer is popular but
they can't afford to do one without the
other so but yeah me me myself I like
having the single-player
I've always enjoyed playing
single-player first get into the game
you know the mechanics and everything
whatever and then jump up multiplayer so
it is kind of disappointed but hopefully
hopefully it doesn't go how sovereign
thinks fast let me double down are you
surprised that remember when twin Zod
got announced
no single it got dragged by the media
like I can't believe this is happening
you know a lot now granted they had the
analytics but you know it did get dry or
you surprised how much success
this game has still still has without
this anyway
also you know majority of the people
that there are there are people I know
people who only game just to play Call
of Duty facts you know and that those
are the majority of people who buy the
consoles so they all they want to do is
play multiplayer no I stopped and said
we are in the minority who'd like to
play the player and that's just it's sad
but that's just the way it is Todd you
know Asaf I need you on this man like
what do you feel you surprised by this
uh the black ops for success actually I
am I'm really surprised because it's
been in a downward spiral for a while
the last few games and so I thought
really this is like the death knell for
them taking up campaign or you know the
campaign model and but obviously it just
shows that I don't know [ __ ] because we
look at they're they're selling
gangbusters so
I'm surprised I don't think that
necessarily it's gonna you know ruin a
lot of games because a lot of companies
aren't Activision you know I mean
there's or will on others like you know
like an EA does you know but you see the
pushback the EA is getting when it comes
to micro transaction and stuff like that
so I I really don't think that a lot of
games are gonna go you know strictly
online and you know you know Battle
Royale style but you never know there
might be one or two I never think like
battlefield will but like you said
specifically those EA games that you
look at battlefield right and and it's
to me it's just one of those things
where they're constantly moving away
from the traditional model of a
single-player campaign right one story
yeah you know different like locales and
stuff like that now but but do they want
do they want to be like oh you're just
copying Call of Duty because they've
been hearing that for 15 years you know
I mean do they want to further that by
saying oh yeah you know what even though
they're really copying pub G and
fortnight I don't under me but I mean
let's be honest everyone just assumes
they oh what's called a duty that they
did it my hope is that EA the push back
EA got because of loot crate Fiasco is
enough for them to look at this and be
like you know what we have the paper
only whatever that is and not follow
suit with this and anus and hope that we
find the same success that they do with
this model already but it's a I don't
know man sometimes EA feels like they
are the most cookie cutter follow like
follow the leader type and it's crazy
because they should be the leaders right
they should be up there and sometimes
they feel like they're not we'll see you
know it's funny it's like if Activision
is the evil empire then you know that EA
is like what the Senate you know I mean
like they go hand in hand you know I
mean they're both big huge conglomerates
and you know they they basically they're
paving the way for all the other little
companies and but you but didn't look at
Ubisoft ooby's died there in their own
lane you know micro-tears actually you
guys you know get your hate from your
fans everything we're gonna continue to
do our thing over here and
and we're you know what we're printing
money over here so yeah yeah definitely
needs to do something and and I hope
it's not taking single player campaign
no wait I feel you man okay I need you
on this man okay
first it's the fortnight effect okay
alright but I see I see these games
going the opposite way of fighting in
another fighting games reckoned it is
and have no story
yeah then Along Came Tekken and force
the story and then fighting had to have
some type of story like link to it and
either some people did a good or some
people really didn't do it well and they
were always playing catch-up to Tekken
well right now fortnight and you can say
pub G first and all this other stuff and
the Battle Royale style uh and with no
story just pop it out into the world and
let's get busy that is successful now
we'll call of duty did was and I'm have
to counter southbound because as US guys
who don't care for Call of Duty and only
you know we play distinct the
single-player first and like I do that
too then if I get a chance to play the
multiplayer I'll do it
I have a lot of guys that don't care a
one squat about the single-player and
only played a blank on the information
too
so all these screams that were coming
out before this game came out and I was
one of them Oh what no multiplayer I
mean no single-player where are you
crazy we are the minority
alright we are the haters that we were
yelling that out and the dudes that were
ready to line up to buy is the ones that
was like good I was money give us more
content in this area we don't care
anything about any numbers reflect that
these dudes they are the majority they
are the ones that control the narrative
now as far as EA goes listen this is the
humorous EA had it speak a long time ago
to K came in and they started selling a
basketball game for 20 bucks and took
the foundation for
under them right Call of Duty came and
took the battle um
battlefront of battlefield front from
under them what EA has to do and for
sovereign to understand it's going
forward EA has to do bargain basement
prices right these games have to come
out at $20 a shot to sell volumes at a
lower rate to enroll the the fanbase
from the other games in order to get
back shares right so you have to go low
for a little while to bring it back high
and it's not gonna happen because these
guys like sovereign said is looking at
the numbers and they're trying to give
you the least amount of effort and I'm
gonna say that because it seems like
when I played that one playing the
battlefield and I was like wow really
like man I was looking forward to them
having the single-player I wanted to be
to prove the dudes wrong I'm gonna play
a single play and once I played the
single-player I didn't buy the game it
was it was it was it was like
half-hearted I said I really don't care
to play the multiplayer but if you'da
gave me to rule by a single player like
you showed in the trailer and like it
looked like I would have really
supported you guys and it just seems
like they dropped the ball when they had
the opportunity to galvanize the the the
single-player experience people and push
them in that direction but I see going
forward
a lot of these games removing that whole
aspect of single-player because if it's
not selling there's no need for it and
they might as well didn't even have it
in battlefield it was like a tack on
yeah I mean let me jump in I mean at any
days like I was surprised about go loves
no surprise though two fronts one that
redhead was actually defeated because I
definitely did I still have a form of
that is true I didn't know even with
just a ninety you know so strong out
here it wasn't a fair fight as far as
length of dales so we got to give red
there that
three days like I mean you know they got
analytics you know clean they they got
it in front of them and as much as you
know we need the hardcore the minority
and everyone you know hate the fact that
they removed it that that numbers show
and I'm saying that it still was
successful so I'm very curious also to
see how red dad actually is gonna do on
next month as well you know as far as
the NPD to see how that plays out yeah
we get a factor in Black Friday because
that that pushes a lot of sales a la
raya and and to soft point you know this
is real key mail because we got to see
how this goes as far as a moving single
play like how you know the industry can
be kind of like a copycat league right
when the battle royal is popping now
people want to put battle royal now
people we call ado he sets the trend
remove single player
now what happens like does the ei you
know does these companies now follow
this mindset you know or is it just a
one-off thing because he OD multi player
is so strong so that they can get away
with it so um you know like I didn't see
this coming you know they bet on
themselves so to speak they would double
down most about in this scenario is
outstanding really outstanding in a lot
of ways outside
in terms of popularity that the
multiplayer stuff you know multiplayer
yeah but that single-player campaign for
titanfall - it was amazing yeah but you
but you have to remember they went I'm
for one launch exactly it to bed you
know I don't think they can go back to
that I agree with no but the thing that
model wasn't prevalent now say now that
now you have you have Cod as the
blueprint right it's different it's not
it wouldn't be exactly the same thing
right they might not come out because
they aren't they working on a Star Wars
game as well no reason development so
much
I thought that game was so outstanding I
thought titanfall 2 was so outstanding
it worse them but like for putting that
so close with the window but I see what
you're saying yeah I think I agree with
self in the sense that on with titanfall
specifically because they launched with
no campaign and got so much back you
know backlash for that to comes out has
a great campaign but I think it just a
victim of the release
well yeah cuz I mean you go to a
restaurant and the first time you first
thing you eat is trash then you know you
get talked into sums oh you know this
comeback you know they got something
else on the menu and you go back and you
eaten so you know what that was pretty
good mm-hmm if you go back a third time
in his trash you know wash that taste
out your mouth like after I go to a
trash restaurant the first time I'm
super reluctant to ever show my face
there again those people that purchase
Titan for the first time they looked at
the second time was it's not gonna
happen bro even if you gift me the game
I'm not gonna play it so you know it's
really putting that bad tasty amount
from the first time don't forget the
first time it was a xbox exclusive right
yeah I think this is let you finish it
move on but I thought this was a great
topic interesting to see I worry about
those type of games because of this
anything that draws me to those games as
those single-player campaigns like you I
mean there's no way in hell you should
release a Star Wars game without a great
single player campaign same thing with
battlefield you have so many stories you
can draw from like
you you can come up with a single-player
campaign if you it's just a matter of
the time and the effort and the money I
know it's all those things have to come
in line but I think again like titanfall
if it does come out it is to have that I
don't see it going back I don't see it
being successful if it goes back to this
formula no I want I just hope that this
is an isolated thing Bluffs Oh blossom
oh I hope call of duty moving forward
something need to have second player no
but I just don't think it's a wrap no I
think I think let's take that money
without it I would not surprise a couple
of months out from the release of the
next game cuz you think you know what it
is solve they still have zombies they
still got black I mean the armed
blackout mode to supplement so it's like
they've already proven no we can live
without this and let's be real in
defense to them we won't play Lord shale
for a minute like these campaigns ain't
cheap man these voice acting this CGI
long but it showed they put a lot of
time into it like like I keep said it
wasn't his attack on in date you know
they they put their minds to it and you
know and they really did a good job
that's why I enjoyed so much that's why
I'm bothered by it and not being there's
absolutely absolutely I mean again I
hear what you guys are saying at the
same time if I don't quote me but I
remember them having analytics in the
number was like 10 percent some very as
much as the hardcore we'd love to do it
and we felt these campaigns are great
the numbers were saying the casuals
ain't doing is they go and they blow
they jumping in and they launching
multi-play and they trying to prestige
from day one what's attitude is that the
the developers who are working on a
single-player campaigns if the studios
say you know we're not gonna do campaign
then there might be some developers out
of a job yeah very interesting to see so
we gonna move on I'm up
Xbox division sous-chef but oh yeah man
so basically looks like that you know
this shadow to our gear nuke
these guys believe was Daniel Connie's
that's about the article first and yeah
pretty much they set up an Xbox division
um basically start partnerships with
Japanese and Asian developers we saw
some job listings and we know in the
past previously or Phil Spencer and idea
Xbox Chris charla those guys are kinda
responsible for going out Japan in these
regions and kind of establishing and
closing these deals but for what we are
learning this Microsoft global gaming
partnership in development is a division
that's dependent on the branch of Xbox
and part of those um basically requiring
myself of this job listing the details
so it looks like this is the place of
residence is not fixed so it doesn't
everybody requires you to hit Tokyo
South Korea Shanghai also Redmond and
the purpose of the regional team should
be to close agreements with potential
partners the candidate will be the
representative of Xbox in the territory
and then it said that they should deal
with the studios and developers to
detect opportunities they'll be in
charge of several people so pretty much
this is looks like Xbox is kind of set
up shop in an area of weakness so I want
to bring this to the Lord's and what can
you run first what do we make of this
the xbox asian division and you know how
what do you feel for the future hit me
in the head with the PlayStation lis
crap time out let this leak out yo
you're seeing his petty like your very
eyes yo Jess who grinding gears baby get
some gears grinding I told you when he's
in a position of power he'll put their
foot on the neck the neck is being
choked out right now just is when the
neck is though he goes to your backyard
puts a house out
he's right now recruiting like yo you
don't like it over there you wanna make
games over he sell a mixtape
he pulled up he popped the trunk he got
the mixtapes out right now
well the studios are being built right
now so he he he out there doing man when
I saw it is somebody said well Microsoft
never so well in Japan anyway so why I
go back there mm-hmm I feel you brother
mmm I feel what you're saying I know you
heard you're tired of being spawned from
the beautiful girl at the dance I know
you wanna you know what Phil did Phil
said hey I'm gonna do a full body
makeover I gots to see how they move out
here he checks he looked at the
landscape he saw how they moved out
there cuz he's trying to move New York
wait I'll say that don't work like that
go out there learn the culture figure it
out oh no bring home but he comes for
your back he said Xbox gets no credit
from Google them figure them out go go
like follow subscribe and then you get
all the information as it trickles down
to you Phil did this for you like when
those games start coming out of Japan
and the Asian continent and they start
actually selling more than to him
because they saw 204 last month when I
son without promotion okay to sell 204
without promotion means there's an
audience out there that wants to get on
board what happens when the promotion
comes what happens when the games is out
there what happens when they have
something small enough to fit inside
these small homes that this culture
doesn't buy multiple consoles they buy
one stick with one alright and a rock
like that
you might get you might have a switch in
a Playstation maybe but if they choose a
switch they rock with the switch let me
let me ask you this King what are you
I'm a double down like what do you hope
to come out of this what are you hoping
to come out what are you really
realistically we know what you think
might right before that deck so what was
gonna go down still gone we'll build a
studio he's gonna get top-notch talent
now maybe somebody talent you'll say oh
you know who that guy is but then you
start going to the colleges you start
going to these or these what can I say
these after schools that have my comedy
on mannequin right yeah you start giving
them jobs right you start getting this
fresh young minds what's on the cutting
edge of what's going on these hungry
developers these new guys that are born
in that area that knows what's what's
hit what's happening there don't go
after the old heads if they come in to
oversee it fine if you can get a big
fish fine for cultivate they're young
you'll start ready roll because you're
already buying studios left and right
mm-hmm and that's over here so you sure
enough this over here but to show in
your weakness that you're doubling down
and you're putting the effort in the
right area you're not going over there
buying like a Miss Walker and and
signing a couple of games here and then
no what you're doing is you're actually
setting up shop there so when when you
go to a restaurant right how likely are
you to go to a food truck or to go to a
restaurant
might be right but you know permanence
see residence that is something to do
with that resonance with the permanence
that equals confidence and Phil
understands that he understands you have
to move different we tried it the one
way let's try it
mm-hmm no this is good now when it
already gets faster differ fast chirping
and chomping at the bit so let's get
faster man what do you feel about this
whole thing man this Xbox easing the
vision what do you get with this well I
mean you know if somebody said in chat
you know well they should have done this
back then it to me none of that means
nothing it doesn't matter what matters
mmm you know this could like you were
saying this could help bring in some
young talent we could see some games it
coming in to Xbox ecosystem that not on
other platforms
you know I guess some GOP dragon I do
you know yeah we need some jail free
cheese and you know get to the point
where someone can say well I don't like
playing xbox they don't have the games I
like but then when you start bringing
the games that people like then what's
your Excuse that's that facts maybe they
needed that you can you know yes they
struggled in the Asian market especially
Japan but they need to keep going you
can't just say well we fell let's forget
about it
no game there's gaming in in Japan just
game into China and South Korea you need
to be in those markets you need to find
out what makes those gamers there take
what do they like mmm xbox needs to
bring games get work with the Asian
developers I mean that that market likes
and that game could work here in the US
and in Europe then you bring it over
they need to do this you know Sony's all
over the world
Sony has is in that market you know of
course that's their bad
they're at home so you know I feel you
man I feel um bring harmony still on our
neck he said late to the party as usual
Xbox division seems to have a hard time
multitasking I'm gonna give them less
self did you go and check the Black
Friday deals because this JRPGs in there
and if you claiming that there's no
JRPGs going their support brother come
on let's go what do you feel about this
bag why you know I actually with the
restaurant so what did I miss
xbox the partnership with Japanese and
Asian developments so pretty much they
look like they're setting up shop out
there as opposed to the past where you
don't feel and Chris Sharla we kind of
just fly out there crying okay you know
I'm not gonna sit there and say yeah you
know what they're taking over Japan
that's never gonna happen
right I think that what they're trying
to do is try to bridge that gap a little
bit for like you know we're talking on
the JRPGs and RPGs for over here in the
West not not you know to sell you know
25 more xbox's in Japan I just think
you're trying to broaden horizons a
little bit and you know trying to brings
more games to us and then I mean how can
you hate on that yeah it may be late it
should have been done 10 years ago blah
blah blah hey that's nice 2020 everybody
can be an armchair quarterback but the
fact that matter is it's better late
than never
facts which shown at one Big Time Lords
are very curious about you stole my
point
I mean I honestly at this point I don't
really care how successful Xbox is in
Asian markets
I really don't what I do care is that
they have a good relationship with those
that development community to again
satisfy the the fervor that we have for
Asian style games here in the West I
look at you know the you know what you
know Dragon Quest persona near stuff
like that like all that stuff has been
big the past couple of years and Xbox
movers for the most part I haven't had
access to that stuff I know we just got
near some stuff moving down the pipeline
but I think for me that's the biggest
thing um there's been people say like
the Japanese gaming market the core
gaming market never went away then
development community never went away
but Jack you know jack
Japan is has shifted so much towards
portable gaming towards mobile stuff
that yeah you saw this big sort of ditch
where there was nothing there for the
core gamer mom either in Japan or here
so now oh yeah the fact that they're
over the yes you did it happen a long
time ago yes absolutely but again a lot
of those bridges got burned for whatever
reason those lines communication weren't
open and now they are but I really care
for it I really care about how that
affects us and what we get on earth I
don't care about anything like yo Sean P
which I wanna shout out on Sammy
Prescott
he said blue dragon and ello Louis
Odyssey was some of his favorite games
last gen he'll 360 had eternal Sanada
till the first and then infinite
discovery Last Remnant and I don't know
what the f happened well friends shout
out the clouds bringing back he was
dungeon explore for a child to the
turbotap man we had the turbotap for
that let me jump in on this man I think
first of all I heard the news I think
this is a positive step I really do I
think this is the right approach with
Microsoft here you know instead of like
feel like I said in Chris charges
jumping on a plane make the visit
the singular day or whatever make a deal
it was like the key for them is to set
up shop in a region develop slow I like
that approach who knows what's gonna
come out come out of it but I definitely
it is sound I think what they're doing
the sound it's a new profile shout out
to Phil on Esther king who did that fast
equity definitely you know specific
exclusives or even existing ones like
you know the personas that stuff that
doesn't come on Xbox right you know
those type of titles that will be cool
and I think the missing thing here is
actually the mobile market because we
know that that's really button and in
fact that they also trying to set up
shop in Korea in China so now you tied
in with Project X cloud if and I'm
saying you throw that in you start
throwing in start extending that reach
on these mobile devices and these games
are targeted for those regions and maybe
you have these devs that definitely you
know again cater to that market have
those sensibilities because let's be
real like Microsoft for the most part
has been out of touch with Japanese
sensibility in my opinion you know
saying my humble opinion I feel they're
out of touch so if you have that team
that's there right they setting up deals
they're trying to get maybe do what king
is saying get these young hungry you
know dad's gonna come up you know get
them in the fall maybe in the future you
do eventually have a studio out you
don't mean that there's a lot of
possibilities it may take time it may be
a small step and I know yes it should
have been done a long time ago but I
think this is the right approach and I
think they're not giving up because a
lot of time let's be real King huh it's
never gonna happen out there hands up I
like his determination to UM to keep
going back to shout the DMV fan in chat
Atlas is one of his big Japanese or
companies making exclusive oh yes sir
I'm a 10 say like those things are to me
you have to as much as some people like
hey I don't want that quote-unquote crap
being
use the word it on Sam but at the end of
the day you want variety on your
platform you don't want to just only be
known as the shoe box right you want to
save like 60 like there's people who buy
the system chests for those games so you
want that diversity you want that
variety so we shall see I'm saying what
happens of this but um yeah maybe we're
gonna move on Lord addict I know he's
been having some issues so I'm just
gonna just jump on his topic right quick
he wanted to talk about on pokemons
let's go his impressions I did not pick
it up but um briefly anybody I'm
doubting anybody in this clan will pick
it up what I'm gonna ask let's go
that's the result okay so I do want to
say what flies are they started I do
want to say that uh obviously it was
aimed for the casual you know the
hardcore Pokemon guys obviously um a
little upset at first that this wasn't
the traditional game so to speak but I
just want to say the first game just
redone right is this the complete first
game that came out on the game Gameboy
the monochrome for the first first olds
right the first game is that game with
updated graphics same exact location
same exact way that you do two battles
same exact everything that's what
they're pissed off with because all the
advancements that it did in the series
going up to this right it's been
stripped away you're starting from base
one so that's what everybody's pissed
off about but excuse me from a graphical
standpoint and if you've never ever got
a chance to play the first one this is a
great time for people to new switch
owners has never played a Pokemon game
that you know this and the title is
appropriate because it's let's go
Pokemon let's go let's go let's get it
started
and the new one is coming talking about
Black Eyed Peas
it's just a reintroduction to original
title that you've made maybe never play
you probably came in on diamond pearl or
whatever that fire and you didn't get a
chance to play this one so those
mechanics those advanced mechanics of
the later games aren't in the first game
but you got to take this game for it
being a remaster of the first game and I
want to double down what you see in a
sense also to them
we gotta keep it real like as far as
like I said the hard core my god you
better be pissed you know I'm saying
like I just sort of numbers though they
not play so traditional Pokemon or not
you know the franchise seem to be
getting stronger shout out the Americans
can tell on those numbers and on
Nintendo might still keep those
financial goals that we thought might be
shaky right went before we see all these
big games coming out and uh you know
analysts had a lot of projections for
these guys but um you know we still have
smash they still have smash coming and
also shout out clowns in the chat he
made a point the music he said the music
and switch Pokemon is very relaxing
relaxing don't know if it's worth $60 I
dropped it I feel you clowns cuz I was
gonna get it but they had the nerve to
not have no discount on Black Friday
anybody would jump in on this Pokemon
thing number surprise me at all the fact
that it's kind of that middle ground
between Pokemon go Pokemon and it
doesn't move some of the deeper like the
deeper aspects of gameplay that some of
the later ones have but we're gonna get
that next year it's Pokemon man isn't
gonna gang it's gonna sell gangbusters
no matter what man it could have been a
stick with like a Pikachu noise anyway
so yeah it doesn't surprise me
yeah I I want to see what smash does
what next week we got an axe
smash next week lost office running out
to get that Pokemon day one right
oh yeah how you feel about the series
can I wake up from my slumber now no
Fastback you racing out a day what did
you count no we have a switch you know
if you play smart card but my Pokemon if
you wants it will pop pick it up run you
know Christmas time they put em on and
that sounds like an easy game for her to
get introduced into Pokemon yeah you
fantasizing about Pokemon Oh Xbox yo
shadow slow-mo slow-mo Nintendo would
have done better on Black Friday if they
would have did a sale for the switch I
agree like that's just me we are gonna
move on cuz you gotta wake up the rest
of the panel um Lord King you're up with
a final time Batman Spidey what's going
on
this is it you waited so um on the 20th
I didn't even know I was so deep into
playing God of War that xx came and I
had alert on my phone it says spider-man
dlc ii deals so i downloaded it and what
I've noticed about this dlc in both in
if they're not long you could probably
beat them in two hours no each one of
them um but the content and each one is
very mature right the first content the
black cat DLC revolves around an
illegitimate baby
he stayed him a Spidey scammin I do
oh boy mary-jane she's not but you have
to deal with it from both aspects of uh
I gotta stuff to be a dad
uh I got this woman that I love and she
don't know about this other woman that I
was with and I might have a child all
these so the next one is dealing with
police and rogue feelings on how Officer
can go over the edge with emotion and
hate and how they can commit a crime
that is so egregious that uh it goes
against the cold maybe you get to see
that vulnerability in an officer that is
with you throughout the beginning first
part of the main game and in this DLC
you get a chance to see that individual
go over the edge so in these DLCs I
understand why they're not part of the
main game because let's say you
purchased the game so you can control
the DLCs right uh and you don't want
your child to know about illegitimate
babies the first DLC so if you get the
main game they don't approach that stuff
they approach death and life and taxes
and all that other stuff in there and
this this spider-man is very mature it's
not um as deep like weak you understand
when you play this is why it's my game
of the year well my thing is being that
I see the direction of the DLC do you
think that this is a good way to put
mature m-rated content into a pg-13 game
later on so you could separate that from
the the regular crowd and you can have
the crowd that can purchase the separate
content if they're old enough to deal
with such mad
do you think that's a viable thing going
forward because if that is used and that
model is used I think it reaches a
larger crowd hold on before we bit into
the rest of Lausanne lady I'll begin at
Chester's King why does it Mary J gotta
be so ugly I started again once where
they came out everything fell to the
wayside I started the first DLC yeah
it's still very little a bit um and that
was it
so I haven't gotten into any of the
stuff but I think I think the whole DLC
model stuff is interesting it you know
when you look at like what happened with
Final Fantasy 15 and trying to give you
DLC you know three years removed from
the lords like it's tough to maintain
people's interest in these games
I think spider-man is doing it perfectly
where it's just a few months removed
from the launch of the game it keeps you
invested in a way that other ones don't
it the storylines like the maturity of
the storylines because I think the main
the core story in spider-man is mature
but it just it kind of walks that line
where the kids will still enjoy it and
it's not over their head and a lot of
them seems going in the middle of it
like towards the end the themes the
themes get a little heavier obviously
right and kids may not necessarily be
there for that but I just think it's
perfect because when it comes to DLC
like that I think the people who are
enjoying it more I'm probably the adults
the oldest the the oldest Piderman fans
right give them a more mature story so
close to the launch of the game mm-hmm
great I think especially well you know
thatthat spider-man bundle selling out
like you give him time more and more
content to play so instead if there's
anything beyond this dlc this stretch of
dlc or is that it
I'm not sure I just want to do a so real
quick like what they're doing with the
Simpsons The Simpsons on all kinds of
purposes it's like you know for kids but
when you really pay attention like wait
a minute what do you feel like is it did
you know if you got it or anything yeah
you know I haven't played it but
everybody's loving it so you know what I
mean that's great and and that's cool if
they can really slide in some DLC some
more much here DLC you know because
everyone thinks you know spider-man is
like you know the do-gooder you know the
you know really that the Poindexter of
the crew you know what I mean so like
you know it's nice to you know have some
adult situations that you know they get
to do it that's gonna give you that King
then we get fastback so cure just slow
most point doesn't mind the content his
issues with the content only being two
hours per DLC and this could be started
and finished in one sitting this just
comes out in a month removed from the
launch of the game so that's his issue
what say you King alright so slow-mo I
think it's 1999 for the all three of
them right so if you add up all three
you say that is six hours of gameplay
for 1999 right and you have other
challenges and stuff like that you can
do that you can press the ijen I feel
the two hours is fitting for that small
storyline that they're doing and they
leave it in an episodic way that leaves
you with a cliffhanger because the whole
DLC is connected mmm but it's different
stories that are the main stories in
each DLC the way they're breaking it
down and if that was part of the game we
wouldn't be crying about it but being
that we see it have this mature theme
you see why they were moved it from the
game I think it would have all been
together but I think these these themes
are too mature for the audience that
they intended to sub the game to but
they still wanted this content for us
mmm you see his point let me get our
fast back fast what did you pick up
spider-man no I don't I don't have a ps4
right now so okay but I definitely will
play it and I'll pick up these DLCs
especially being a mature content you
know being an adult yeah I would like to
see other games adopt this where you'll
see where kids can not buy it you know
give us some mature content on some of
them and DLC but no I definitely as far
as this yeah yeah bring keep bringing it
keep bringing it no doubt yeah man this
is a good one I mean from what I
understand King like I'm just happy to
see them support the title you know I'm
saying and my whole thinking I just
don't want this is this is a really good
game right this hope that is not
overlooked at the game awards like for
them to come I'm worried the day
literally can come away with nothing the
hype behind God of War in the hide
behind Red Bull grand is crazy but see
this is where those game awards is taken
with a grain of salt because addict said
his game of the year is Assassin's Creed
last year my game of the year was
Assassin's Creed I really didn't care
about anybody else's opinion when it
came to that so if the wars can come and
go don't miss out on a game because it
didn't receive an award oh absolutely
a lot of people do doesn't get a perfect
ten like now eight is almost
unsatisfactory right yeah if you get if
you don't get a nine or a ten and that's
why I guess I had my yeah it was on the
same page with the ten thing is because
it to me just devalues it we throw in
the tens out so much now eight nine
comes along and for example it's a
Spider Man is in that range now people
like always I but got a wall you know
saying but right there now we talking
right when they gave five makes out I
remember when Lee Chi needle stop
reading the sauce mm-hmm they gave five
Mike's out to somebody that did not
deserve we knew that they might see
about that so right see what you just
said Wow what I'm and we all know that
that's nope album was then you can go
cotton off all day and facts matter what
cost you from these games I'm telling
you God was not five Mike's I don't care
how do you feel do what I did in it and
it doesn't have no content it shows you
places you can't go gets me so worked up
by seeing Asgard right there and I can't
click it because it says Odin says no yo
throw this game away that's how I feel
spider-man doesn't have that same thing
I gotta ask you to Victor Houston wants
a question for you said with the success
of spider-man is there a chance Marvel
takes control of MCU games as they could
be a new potential goldmine and they
want would want to avoid losing the
games to different publishers
no well Sony is of spider-man and Sony's
so that dad that dad has absolutely
nothing to do with it the developer is a
sucker punch so um that it within itself
as a whole Sony thing um Disney
controlling what's going on remember
Disney infinity they had all that Marvel
stuff they did all of that that stuff
sold they did take control remember you
didn't get uh that what was the Marvel
vs. Capcom you lost uh
Wolverine and stuff like that until they
able to purchase Fox they they took
control of the IPS so but are they gonna
make a game yeah pretty much so then the
movies is telling will it be of this
caliber I don't think they'll make games
themselves they just want to have more
control about yeah exactly yeah no fair
enough fair enough yeah Ben and like I
said back to experiment they're just I
heard good things you know definitely
get into it actually like the fact it's
kind of a short burst because there's an
older game I don't got time to be
playing these 25 hours so like little
quick bursts getting get out and I heard
that it's better what is this one is
this the heist or just the mr. name of
this one is this one is the heist no my
first one is the heist this one is yeah
the second one is a different name but I
heard that the second one is definitely
more improved on turf wars tours they
regularly they serious yo I said one
time in a board and I'll it because you
have to go inside these boards right and
you have to take over hammerheads turf
right turf wars and you have to go
inside and you have to clear it out and
have they send waves at you mm-hmm these
guys are tougher than the last one
late I don't know I was clearing them
out before with no problem but right now
it's very hard for me to get to three
stars
yes Iceland Issei was turf war and last
one fight is called silver lining
his arm so yeah I mean like I said I'm
glad to see the support and I'm
definitely glad to see like I said they
were improving on it doing mature themes
I'm definitely one dust off that's
fighting at that poppin but that's what
I got on it we are gonna get ready to
close our arm you know so new ILP poll
this week it's inspired by Lord saw with
the MVD sales success of call of duty
black ops for removing a traditional
single-player campaign in favor for
multiplayer centric modes how concerned
are we there other titles of the same
vein follow suit with this practice
choices are a very concerned publishers
have the analytics and want to mimic
similar profit success be not concern
cod is an anomaly 2018 has proven
traditional single player is here to
stay
or see I don't care it was all fun and
games until CEO D stole that battle
royal mole at the end of the show
tomorrow
Lord fastback Lord southbound you in a
row both of you honor the ball thank you
Oh what can people find this though a
lot of fast pack where can the five
people find you and what do you have
going on out here alright so now that
the past the Thanksgiving you can find
me Bekka OG n OG at 9:30 Eastern I said
I can't miss another one so much paid
time off me and then WD FC like I said
we we try to do it every other week
we're gonna probably go to Friday's soca
I don't that sure if we're beyond next
Friday but I mean you know tweeted out
and I you know W sees this whenever you
know who def cares shuttle to the crew
but it's not the LG's thing HD came
crazy all the cruise
WMC my main dad's and batteries that's
what we call them now you got so many
names language for the Lord's Day we'll
get a moon we got that shout out the
witty shout the coupe man great Google
guys please check these guys out there
again Friday's gonna be there it looks
like right you know start popping and
nlgi believe it is Friday with at 9:30
stinger yeah great podcast you define a
podcast community bring them together
great Google glass salut fastback this
was long overdue
absolutely and Lord southbound the ledge
royalty today graced us with his
presence tremendous knowledge jokes for
days i'm using scamming from now on of
itself man good to have you wake and if
i'm people find you yeah you know what
you can catch me all down twitter at
southbound 110 you know I think here in
the short-term future I'll be popping up
on some more podcast listener ever since
I got back across Friday night I was
like you know what I got I got the
flavor man Twitter you know or give me
an Xbox my gamertag is south not for
sale we're not selling some high numbers
of like follow your timeline and you
when you put up those Xbox loud or
screen caps of how much money people are
why that's why I go why would you want
it so bad like really you want to give 7
racks for
[Laughter]
with these high rags yeah but now but
seriously I appreciate you guys having
me on it's been an honor I got much love
for all you guys good to see you back
out there pocket just like riding a bike
man let you get back in it I see you got
the groove shot the crossfire mooching
them do the heard you last that night on
Friday that was good situation too but
oh he'll be back King held you down on
their Pokemon I know you want to get
your point O Lord saw back in the
building man we can find people first
big shout out to southbound and fast
like we're coming through like I said
this is long overdue
Oh through coming through guys and I
hope to meet you guys
advance this yeah I'm finally I'm
traveling this year so I'll be around a
magazine corn yo the system let's go
only um yeah you guys can find me find
me back on red dead this week continuing
my murderous waves and Red Dead later on
and you can find me on Twitter Lord saw
by Opie and being sovereign or PSN and
xbox Oh Lord
King in the building push through the
sickness and all the Lords in the realm
what's going on we can find you man
first of all I like to give a shout out
to Fastback just so bound and to bury
pawns fill spit them so that you guys
came through I saw who was showing up I
was praying that southbound made it if
y'all didn't know there was a couple of
times that you know something I was
supposed to be on and for other
circumstances it didn't happen and I
really love this dude I got pictures
with this dude look at our Instagram
he's up there man on the black onyx
Wilson again Joe Pesci I'm so honored to
have you guys here and like Cognito said
is royalty in the building and you know
bend the knee much respect to you guys
for paving the way and still doing what
you do not get enough credit for the
positivity they actually bring bringing
people together everyone enjoys their
company so we've got to salute them on
that two minute Rob's doing all right so
this week you got the spotlight coming
with Deontay Wilder then enticing fury
I'm doing something different this week
for combat talk with the king so you got
to get that this week separate before
the weigh-in before the fight because
the fight is coming as you see these
boxes that's in the bag I got more boxes
upstairs in the foyer
Kos and Kos lid
I just commissioned intro and intro
music for many music I hope y'all know
yeah
yours oh that's nothing compared to
Arcade Kings beat that's coming for the
arcade King our you're gonna check that
out that's coming to have a system that
I'm getting built from tiny arcade
machines in Spain so when that gets here
- snows gonna be up - listen follow us
on Instagram Facebook Twitter what else
am I missing cause I know something else
do we get absolutely ma'am yeah man like
I said shout everybody in the chat today
make sure you hit that like subscribe on
the channel more stuff coming man shout
out to the stream teams now though
l-boogie
saw in the chat Lord MJ Youngblood and
of course the new addition Lord the Lupo
potentially perfect he's got some great
content out on the channel man please
check him out he's got a review up a
hilarious review of a game if you want
to find out about a game the level go
give you that out the dizzy the sin of
the team I'm saying we got stuff going
on a site tip break that news you know
car box are gonna have to order you
later and of course make sure you guys
still sign up for that a smash giveaway
it's coming soon when is that closing
down stuff should be very soon but I
believe that it's right before the game
get on that gleam and our smash giveaway
no doubt baby you already know the iron
bank has spoken and of course no flash
point this week our artist was with the
fame doing it Thanksgiving but we will
come back next week give you that
destiny only content that you love but
the end and that's what we got man
everybody if everything else we're gonna
enjoy our Sunday everybody's good
alright pigs